making a movie might seem like
relatively harmless make-believe most of
the time but sometimes those fake action
scenes have painful consequences from
action stars to comedy legends all these
actors got knocked out while making a
movie few actors have been bonked and
bruised in the name of cinema quite as
often or as famously as jackie chan he
broke his eye socket while shooting
1978's drunken master he dislocated his
pelvis and sustained second-degree burns
and spinal damage while shooting the
explosive pole slide conclusion of
police story he even cracked his skull
open while shooting 1986's armor of god
arguably the most serious and
squirm-inducing injury in his career
that particular injury in fact is so
famous that chan has invited other
celebrities to occasionally feel the
hole where a part of his skull used to
be according to his autobiography i am
jackie chan my life in action jan was
also knocked unconscious while filming
the 1976 movie hand of death as chan
tells it he hit his head after a stunt
that involved a particularly daring fall
despite the pain of the impact he
immediately performed the stunt again to
get the shot before finally passing out
supposedly director john woo was
convinced that chan was going to die
until the actor woke up an hour later
unfortunately this would prove to be his
first major concussion in a career full
of them
frankly it's a miracle that the
legendary buster keaton made it out of
the movie-making business in mostly one
piece heck the man broke his ankle while
goofing off on a movie staircase during
the shoot of the electric house and
according to marion mead's keaton
biography cut to the chase the silent
star even fractured his neck during the
filming of sherlock jr when a geyser
from a water tower knocked him flat
keaton a genius of both physical comedy
and death defying action sequences
famously never refused a stunt however
dangerous in 1926 is the general
keaton's retelling of the true civil war
story of a runaway locomotive stolen by
union spies keaton was knocked
unconscious when he was standing too
close to a civil war replica cannon that
fired prematurely that's commitment to
craft
in the second cinematic outing of jason
bourne the bourne supremacy everyone's
favorite amnesiac cia assassin has his
peaceful life threatened by a conspiracy
involving russian documents which
naturally has something to do with the
nefarious operation treadstone borne's
covert adventure takes him to an airport
in naples where he allows himself to get
spotted by security and taken into
custody during his interrogation he
overpowers cia officer john nevins to
get his sim card as director paul
greengrass explains on the film's
director's commentary the execution of
the fight scene didn't quite go as
planned reportedly born star matt
damon's flying fists actually came into
contact with tim griffin the actor
playing nevins accidentally knocking him
out cold while greengrass's infamous
shaky cam makes the hit hard to catch if
you have the luxury of replaying the
punch frame by frame you'll indeed be
treated to a high speed smack that looks
like it hurt big time to his credit from
what we see on screen damon doesn't
break character hey remind us not to
mess with matt damon
what if death race 2000 was a whimsical
slapstick comedy well good news that
movie exists and it's called the great
race blake edwards 1965 film tells the
unapologetically capitalistic tale of
professional daredevil the great leslie
who convinces automotive manufacturers
that a race from new york to paris will
increase car sales the great leslie's
arch nemesis the mustachioed black
suited professor fate vows to vanquish
his blue-eyed foe by way of a car of his
own invention that features among other
things hydraulic stilts the great race
is the proud recipient of a couple of
cinematic superlatives including what a
1965 edition of life magazine dubbed as
the greatest pie fight ever the scene
featured 4 000 cream pies on one massive
set and was shot over five days as fun
as the ordeal sounds things steadily
took a turn for the dangerous as the
shoot wore on in the life article star
jack lemmon who played professor fate
claimed that he got knocked out a couple
of times noting that getting smacked
with a high-flying pie feels quote like
a ton of cement the same article
describes how at one point actress
natalie wood choked briefly when a pie
flew directly into her mouth who knew
pies could be so dangerous
bad boys is a seminal piece of 1990s
action cinema as well as a testament to
the on-screen power of both will smith
and director michael bay the film tells
the story of two miami cops one a family
man the other a womanizer who have 72
hours to reclaim heroin stolen from
their station's evidence storage locker
actress taya leone was along for the
ride as julie the sole witness to a
murder and someone who requires the
protection of the title characters
during the filming leone was
accidentally knocked unconscious by
co-star martin lawrence's stunt double
as the actress explained to movie line
in a 2000 interview it was the ak-47
under the jaw that got me i wasn't on
the proper mark when the stunt guy hit
me with it my legs went over my head and
i landed flat on my back didn't have
much memory at that point as she tells
it bae quote freaked out about her
ability to finish the film leone was
able to pull through and became a part
of action movie history with the
injuries to prove it
bloodsport is a film that could easily
be retitled jean-claude van damme versus
the world the film is a delightfully
flagrant excuse to showcase the actors
talents for taking and dishing out
beatings van damme plays dukes a skilled
fighter invited to participate in an
illegal martial arts tournament in hong
kong known as the kumite determined to
bring honor to his stateside father
figure dukes accepts the challenge and
proceeds along the long and bloody
journey of beating up the best of the
best one of the best is sadiq hossein
played by bernard mariano during their
brawl hussein refuses to stay down and
lurches forward from his defeated
position on the floor to challenge dukes
for a second go round the script called
for dukes to land a definitive punch to
keep hussein down for good unfortunately
for mariano van damme's elbow actually
made contact with his jaw which you can
see for yourself in the final film
mariano later told the south china
morning post that the blood you see in
the scene isn't movie magic either
one of the most memorable scenes in rob
reiner's fairy tale comedy classic the
princess bride takes place when the
newly reunited wesley and princess
buttercup make their way through the
treacherous fire swamp which is exactly
what it sounds like unfortunately the
pair's happy reunion is short-lived they
survive the mythical creatures known as
rodents of unusual size and even pull
their way out of quicksand only to fall
prey to the ambush of the dastardly
prince humperdink when it came time to
film the shot where the prince's
right-hand man count rugen slugs the
injured wesley with the butt of his
sword the blow didn't look quite
convincing enough on camera in his
memoir as you wish wesley actor carrie
elwes recalled that the reiner's
solution to the problem of making the
hit look real made him quite literally
see stars as he explained in the book
the camera angle meant that a fake
strike just didn't look right so he told
count rugen actor christopher guest to
just quote hit me hard guest landed a
blow with the butt of his sword and
elwes woke up in the hospital
released 16 years after rocky 5 rocky
balboa is the sixth entry in the saga of
underdog boxer rocky balboa and catches
up with the aging philadelphia prize
fighter in retirement he's in his 60s
widowed and has a strained relationship
with his son when a simulation predicts
that superstar professional boxer mason
dixon would lose to rocky the undefeated
dixon throws down the gauntlet in the
hopes of finally fighting a true
contender to everyone's surprise rocky
agrees and comes out of retirement as
reported by the guardian rocky balboa
star sylvester stallone was actually
knocked unconscious during the shoot and
the crew kept filming because they
thought it was all part of the actor's
performance in his most famous role
according to the report mason dixon
actor antonio tarver accidentally
punched stallone in the head while
shooting a fight scene in a las vegas
ring where the 59 year old actor
promptly collapsed after the crew
realized that no stallone was not acting
they rallied emergency services to tend
to him he was rushed to the hospital and
thankfully made a full recovery
ryan coogler's rocky spin-off movie
creed sees former world heavyweight
champion rocky balboa serving as both
mentor and trainer to adonis johnson the
son of balboa's late friend and former
boxing rival apollo creed somewhat
appropriately for a film intent on
revisiting old ground jordan partook in
the time-honored rocky tradition of
getting laid out for real now you wanted
this let's go cruise i want you to make
it up a behind-the-scenes tweet by none
other than stallone himself showed
jordan taking a mean right hook from his
co-star very real professional fighter
tony bellew and falling flat on the
floor on the graham norton show jordan
recalled that the real punch was
orchestrated by stallone to achieve a
convincing slow motion shot
unfortunately the first time they did
the real punch belu's glove got in the
way of the camera so they had to do
another take and it's this second hit
that dropped jordan like a sack of
potatoes while the actor assured the
talkshow host that he wasn't technically
unconscious he admits because i was i
was definitely seeing stars it was
definitely not i was not all there
smelling the canvas and everything i'll
never forget it
while promoting guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 on live with kelly and ryan chris
pratt relayed the details of a stunt
gone wrong in his latest outing as
marvel's star-lord pratt explained that
he got knocked out while he and an
unspecified co-star were filming some
wire work as pratt describes in the
interview the accident was the result of
the stunt happening too fast according
to the star he was trying to land on his
shoulder when he hit his head on a
protective mat instead thankfully the
moment of unconsciousness was brief and
i realized if i don't do this scene
right now i'm going to have to do this
stunt again given the amount of rig and
wire work involved in the guardian
sequel we're not even going to try and
guess which specific scene was being
filmed when pratt came crashing down
maybe one day he'll tell the whole story
wes craven's 2005 airborne thriller red
eye tells the story of lisa a woman
kidnapped by a stranger on a routine
commercial flight bound for miami with
her father's life in the balance lisa
finds herself dragged unwillingly into
assisting her menacing captor in the
assassination of a politician in one
scene stars killian murphy and rachel
mcadams duke it out in an airplane
bathroom at the beginning of the
confrontation murphy rushes at mcadams
pinning her against a wall however while
filming the scene it seems murphy
miscalculated and mcadams hit her head
for real and supposedly lost
consciousness for a moment the incident
is included in the film's gag reel so
clearly there were no hard feelings if
you look closely during the actual scene
as it appears in the film you can catch
murphy's hand protecting mcadam's head
from future injury how sweet check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you